[Music]
have you guys heard
of what kopi oh is
beat oh cool i think i've seen a
restaurant like that
in like austria that's not the drink is
it
calpico no oh that's what i was thinking
but not calpico yeah
okay so kopi oh is a
type of traditional malaysian coffee
also known as coffee
kopi oh kopi i don't know how to
pronounce it
malaysia got some good ass food and
drinks coffee yeah
i want it yeah it's good you should save
a buddy and go let's
try and save money but like be careful
because i like corona
oh damn i don't think i plan on
traveling this year joe
ah i'm gonna do it yeah nice
okay so kofi uh it was used
in this image uh that portrays
it to be used with salmon
oh i seen this [ __ ] i was like what the
[ __ ] dude
is it delicious hell no i like the
little
soy sauce bath so that's what they're
saying it's like kind of like replacing
soy sauce to be with coffee and they're
saying that this is a new malaysian
trend
and malaysians are like no the [ __ ]
is it
who's saying it's malaysian trend maybe
just that company
they're like hey guys you wanna you know
you want to know what's new here in
malaysia it's awesome here's coffee and
salmon
oh dude i remember we went to i forgot
whose birthday it was but we went to
this one
um so it was like a steakhouse and then
they had like a coffee covered steak
oh all of us ordered it and it was
[ __ ] horrible
were you there with us i had coffee
steak it was like we had the coffee
stick but it's like not this place
yeah this place was like what did they
do horrible
it was in downtown and there was like
hell of reviews on yelp so we wanted to
go try it
and everyone was talking about it yeah
so like i pretty much like the whole
table
ordered it and it was like coffee
grounds on steak and then i don't know
it just tasted like a coffee steak
i went to the delamo mall and then i saw
it on the menu it was a ribeye steak
with coffee grounds and i was like let
me try it
it was [ __ ] good i remember we were
all just scraping the [ __ ] out of that
what the [ __ ] it's supposed to be like
ground up like to a powder and like it's
like
black pepper yeah and it's supposed to
be very light this one was like the
whole thing the whole thing
it was fuzzy you only buy like those
chocolate truffle things from like
costco
where it's melted chocolate covered in
cocoa powder it was like that the whole
thing was fuzzy looking
gross would you be down and taste it
again if it's good like with joseph oh
love it it's supposed to be amazing
they have the rubs with it they have
everything but that just reminds me if
it's
is that coffee or no it's copy copy
puppy
yeah well do you like coffee so this was
originally
shared on this facebook page where i was
sharing photos of
ways of eating salmon to dump it into
this cup of black coffee i didn't even
know they had salmon down there i
thought that was like a washington thing
in malaysia what yeah so only washington
has salmon
usually i can like kind of follow your
logic but this one
what i think they have so much local
fish
why the [ __ ] would they want a
transatlantic fish
oh cause salmon is not from over there
well that means in the pacific ocean but
i just didn't know that there was salmon
in the southeast of asia
and then if they're working that hard to
ship over fish from america
it's kind of like weird to me i don't
know so only america has salmon
a lot of american like i think this
there's atlantic salmon and there's
pacific city
okay yeah i'm fine
okay besides that though yeah like what
what is the whole thing that they're
doing now
so they're just trying to make it
popular the coffee well
um it's working yeah we're talking about
it yeah
i'm gonna apparently i'm not gonna try
it it's it's just a joke
oh and people took it really like
someone was trolling their friend or
something
because uh nine gag picked it up and
they did a post
and they the headline reads some
malaysians are dipping raw salmon and
coffee for breakfast
is it like hot coffee and it cooks with
salmon
i don't know it doesn't seem like it's
it's the temperature's hot
that's nasty that stand to look good
though i'm not gonna lie that was like
do you guys
you like salmon yeah i love sand but i
can't do it like that
i can only the only thing i don't like
about salmon is when people say salmon
salad yeah that's weird salmon out of
sushi
it's my probably my least favorite food
really really oh i love it do it
interesting
it's the easiest and that's that's why i
guess people mostly like it in japan
there's not
you can't even get salmon that's not
even part of like their freaking
thingamabob they don't have it there
they do yeah they have it but it's it's
not it's not
that big yeah yeah they invented all i'm
saying sam is like the orange chicken at
panda
also not made in china true i
enjoy there was a time where i could
only eat salmon
whenever we would go i hate it as a kid
and i hate it something happened
at one of the all you can eat places
that we went and i think i just got way
too much salmon and i was salmoned out
and i couldn't even touch salmon for
like a couple years
and so now i only have a few pieces but
my favorite is tuna what about yellow
yeah you can't open it yellowtail's my
favorite i can't eat tuna sometimes
because sometimes it has that metallic
taste
yeah that's a good tuna fatty one freeze
burn
yeah i like alva core alcohol
and just a little bit of macro just a
little bit cook salmon i can't eat
cooked salmon why
i just i required the taste for like raw
salmon
and like anything cooked salmon is
pretty gross do you get medium rare
though medium rare is pretty good it's
crispy
on the outside and on the inside it
still tastes raw it's pretty good yeah
yeah like a seared yeah
like really kind of like almost crispy
on the outside that's simon's bomb
that's what i just said yeah he does oh
like he did he did no but you said
medium rare like on the inside no i like
it like cooked throughout
and like i don't like that
but if you cook it properly it's not
gonna be dry yes it is no yep
i just i'm like a bear i just like the
skin i just realized you're not wearing
a shirt it's really good
especially if it doesn't work he is
wearing a snake
he's not wearing underwear either guys
goddamn it was hot outside
you know they take um salmon skin and
they put on burns
yeah i've seen that it's really fatty
and has collagen and everything helps
yeah doctors do that yeah they do that
[ __ ] doctors like in american
hospitals yes we did we
talked about jacob i wasn't even there
you were there
i remember i was sitting right there and
you were right here and you're like how
does that work and then i was like well
they just skim the salmon and then you
just put the [ __ ] skin on that's so
much
so many nutrients nutrients nutrients it
helps with the burn it helps the pain it
helps uh
we're like regenerate dude but salmon
skin is so [ __ ] bomb though like i
would
be like that's a waste i'm going to eat
it dude i literally just salivated right
now
so it's got to be raw you take black
salmon it's going to raw yeah well i
don't know if i could eat no they treat
it they treat it they probably treat it
somehow medically
it's not crispy salmon what do they
torture first should i get a sushi
restaurant i put ginger wasabi
i like crispy salmon skin that's my
favorite hand roll but you could have
the meat that's crispy yeah the crispy
salmon
i can't do skin because i don't like the
texture oh it's so good it's like chips
like oily cheeps yeah when it's crispy
is good but like i can understand that
if it's like the steamed fish and you
still have the skin
i can kind of understand what's your
favorite fish sushi wise then to eat it
raw
tuna yeah tuna blue fin or yeah
uh huh so
no wait is this yeah they're looking at
like just the red
regular tuna tuna no honestly
is my [ __ ] like that 7-eleven [ __ ]
bomb in the plastic
that but i can't have too much of that
because then it gets like way too fatty
it is
it's pretty crazy it kind of tastes like
salmon again like when it's too fatty oh
now i just want to go to like was it
against sushi it was like the one in
that one
um
that place is so [ __ ] good what's
your favorite what's your favorite sushi
what's your favorite waffle fish never
forget the thing my favorite
that's revolving sushi good that's that
revolver sushi is good but you can't
even compare it again though you can't
compare it again
if i take it again oh my goodness i
don't know how like you would say yeah
again yeah it's in the same plaza with
like the matcha ice cream saucer i think
i know what you're talking about yeah
yeah yeah
it's bubba and yeah and where that curry
house used to be right
sushi and yeah is where like yeah
i know curry houses how do we recreate
this then
no you have to get coffee no okay
because i was gonna ask you guys like
even though
knowing that it's it was meant to be as
like a joke would you still be down to
try this no no
if people are like it's bomb i'll try it
yeah i already know what it's gonna
taste like
cocka coffee and i thought he was gonna
take chocolate
yes coffee and salad like it's not that
hard to do you get a cup of coffee you
put a [ __ ] salmon and
it's gonna be it's not thick enough to
coat the salmon
yeah you gotta have really [ __ ]
salmon's gonna get ruined which is like
coffee's gonna get really
like highly cute after there's just like
salmon oil that's just chilling after
you like pull it out
you know it's a trip how they figured
out that like cream cheese and salmon
would be good like locks that used to be
my favorite
roll uh more like before i got cheese
and
hot cheetos that's what i'm talking
about
i don't like cream cheese but like my
brother used to do that all the time you
don't like cream
i don't like a lot of cheese man i
thought oh white people already did that
with like
cured salmon and then they put it on
maybe that's how they got the idea
oh like the philadelphia rolls yeah it's
not much
like onions and capers that's so weird
those are really popular in russia for
some reason
they are i had some right philadelphia
rolls in russia
is like a huge thing they love
philadelphia they love it i'm so
confused because like
sushi called philadelphia in russia
[ __ ] me up every time
the dolphin rolls are [ __ ] weird it's
not sushi i still love them
i don't like them i can't get into yeah
i don't consider them sushi my brain
though i consider like some weird
i just love dairy sushi i'm not a snob
it's just that i'm not used to it
because i didn't grow up eating it so
then when i ate it i was like this is so
[ __ ] weird
what do you think would be the weirdest
thing to pair with salmon then
coffee probably yeah right ketchup
no lemonade way to make coffee uh salmon
and
ketchup not lemonade because you usually
squeeze lemonade true
yeah maybe salmon and dmt that's pretty
crazy i'd rather do that than [ __ ]
coffee
orange no that sounds like it would go
salmon
and bread no that sounds good
i mean you cook salmon milk
wait wait but cream cheese is milk
that's different though
because then you maybe salmon peanut
butter
i feel like you could make what about
salmon skittles anything in peanut
butter kinda
i know that's why i'm like more
chocolate in general have you ever had a
burger with peanut butter on it no no
delicious a what with peanut butter oh i
have had one yes peanut butter jelly
burger yes i have
was it disgusting disgustingly great oh
wait you mean we're like lettuce and
tomatoes and all that didn't put the
lettuce
it was like it was uh peanut butter
uh and jelly and sriracha and then the
burger
oh yeah and by the way because there's
people still asking me till this day i
still have not
received my peanut butter pump i don't
know when it's coming
peanut butter pumpkin what the
kickstarter the kickstarter is still
it's better
six years ago no it's been like two
years oh like a year and a half see i'm
bad with time
yeah what is this peanut butter so it's
like a pump that you put you're supposed
to attach to the actual like
like jar and then you just pump out the
peanut butter
and i bought it on kickstarter and we
even did a jk news on it
and till this day i still have not
received it
and the guy i mean he's really good
about giving updates and you know
coronavirus made it harder because he's
getting it manufactured in china but
i still have not received it i feel like
with that you have to do you have to
microwave it
no peanut butter you scoop it out and it
stays like that yeah no it you're not
you don't you don't need to it just
comes out and it works with chunky too
i think that's how you're trying to make
it work first because it doesn't work
he's gonna come out tomorrow now you
know yeah you gotta buy it with the
microwave
[Music]
you
[Music]